えーと あの 一つ質問があるんですけれども
あの真言密教のお坊さんが書いた本の中に
仏教の中間という本を読んだんですね
それで太陽を例えてこととして
太陽を仏ですね 言われていた
で 例えば水曜 水星と金星とか
地獄 地球 それで地球が地球ね
その中に いわゆるありとあらゆる生命がその輪廻転回をしているということを書いた本を読んだことがあるんですけど
そういうそういうふうに理解してよろしいでしょうか
今 私に言われたところから見ればとんでもない間違いです
仏教じゃないでしょう
これはもうただアニミズムでありながら
ヒンドゥー教でありながら
日本の神道の思考をすべてごちゃ混ぜ
でしょうね 太陽は仏あと太陽はただの火の玉なんですけど
わかりました  もっと難しいんですよ
宇宙の存在はそんな単純じゃないんです
あの気楽にいろいろまあ
質問いろいろ何でもいいんです
はい  えーと 途中で親鸞聖人の話が出たんですけど
うちの母がとても熱心に親鸞聖人のことを信仰していて
今日のお話を聞いて少し不安になったんですけど
私は子供としてどう母どうすればいいでしょうか
あの そんなに心配しなくても
もしね あの この邪見は困りますけど
まあそれでも心は穏やかであるならば
心に嫉妬 怒り 憎しみはなく
明るくいるならばね そんなに心配する必要はないんです
しかし このある一見にしがみついていると
これがちょっと危ないんですね
普通に親鸞聖人を信仰したっても構いませんだけど
これこそこれこそではなくて
穏やかで ごく一般的に誰ともニコッと笑って
あの優しい人で生活しているならば
そんなに危ないということじゃないんです
論理的なポイントは 心が汚れたら困るということで
汚れる一番大きなポイントは
この意見にしがみつくことなんですね
あらゆるどんな意見でもいいんです
それにしがみついたらダメなんですね
だから今の講演でも言ったように
例えばお釈迦様でも反論したってお釈迦様全然そうですねってその話し始めるんです
だから我々人間だからいろんな意見持ってますよ
そこはもう間違いとわかったところで改良すればよろしいんです
どんな意見であっても
無常だからね そんなに執着するには値しませんね
だから心は清らかであるべきということは
もう別に意見ではないんです
経験でしょ 我々は心が汚れるとものすごい不幸になるでしょうね
心が明るく明るい場合は結構うまくいくでしょ
人生は物事はうまくいきますから
明るい心があれば だったら常に明るくいればいいでしょうに
なんでそれをやらないのかと
それっての経験でしょ
だから私たちは明るくいたいんだけど
どうもすぐ暗くなるという
その弱みがあるんで それは仏教で直してあげます
ということで あまりにもそこそこ心配しないでください
はい  では 後ろの方 今日は幸せへの道だということなんですけども
出家されたお坊さんとかはやはり幸せを感じているのでしょうか
だと思いますけど 私は今 64歳になってまだ還俗しようと思ってないんですね
子供の頃出家したんですけどね
親から離れて 13歳で離れてね
家に家に戻りたいとかね
思ったこともないしね
出家した時点で随分安らぎ感じるんです
修行するところじゃないんです
出家しただけででもかなり安らぎを感じます
出家だからすごい自由ですよ
これはなかなかわからないもんですよ
精神的にどちらにも束縛されてないという
だからストレスは人と会ったり喋ったりしない限りはたまりません
結構感じるんですよ 幸せは安らぎということですね
はい では前の人のちょっと手
なんかくらいも手挙げてますけど
じゃあじゃあその人 すみません
えっと あの 死にかかってる人に準備はできたって言うと
かえって倒れちゃうって言いましたね
面白かったんですけど
一番最後にその尊厳を傷つけないでくださいという話があって
その場合もその死にかかってる時に準備はできたって言われて
なんとなくだと尊厳を傷つけられたと思っちゃうかなと
そうじゃないんですね
例えばお前バカやというのは尊厳
傷つくんですよ お前バカなことしか他できないの？と聞けば
もっとまちなことしなさい
バカなことばっかしやらないでという場合は
別に楽しいんです 言われた
言われた方 人も そういう微妙なところなんです
ですから この準備できてないのかということは
これ 仏教の世界だけの話で
内輪話なんです これにはかなりの智慧のレベルがないと
難しいと思います 私にできてもそちらにはできないと思います
私は相手が仏教であってもなくても全然関係ないんです
平気で言えます だからそれなりの後ろ
なんて言いますか あのバックグラウンドサポートありますからね
と言っても 世の中は誰でも死ぬでしょうに
だから先にやるべきことを
死ぬ準備でしょ なんでそれだけしないんですかね
結婚の準備するんですけど
結婚できるかできないかわからないし
で 長生きする準備するんですけど
自分の DNA の中でね
もうがんになるプログラムあるかさっぱりわからないし
もう当てにならないものになんで準備するのかって
しっかり当てになりますよ
人は死ぬっていうこと
それだけは準備してないんだと
これはもう外国に行こうかなと思って
カバン買うわ 服を買うわとか
サングラスも買うわとかね
しかし 飛行機のチケットだけ買ってないんだと
これ準備できているということですかね
サングラスなんかなくても
飛行機のチケットだけあったっても乗れますよ
パスポートと 2つあれば
だから例えば外国旅行するって思って
ちょこっとお金とパスポートと飛行機
点検 それだけでうまくいきますよ
カバンがなくても何なくても
それカバンは買うわ 服は買うわ
これでカバンのブランドも決めるわとかね
梅干しもそれなりにも買っておくわとかね
そこでお湯で溶かして飲める味噌汁のあれば全部準備万端ですけど
チケットだけは買ってないの
お金ないんだと 意味がないんですよ
だから我々結婚の準備するは
仕事あれやこれや何でもやってますけど
死ぬ準備してないんです
あべこべです だから仏教ではもう子供にもはっきり言うんですよ
誰でも死ぬんだから 先に死ぬ準備するんだよと
私はちっちゃい時 もう散々母親に言われるんだから
そんなことやって あんた死なないつもり？というよくそう言うんです
あんた死なないつもりですかね？とかね
喧嘩したりすると そんな喧嘩したり怒ったりして
今までも覚えてるのは
ちょっと体の身体障害ある人が家に来て
ものを置いてきたんですけど
私は初めて見てちょっとびっくりしたんです
ちょっと体の形が違いましたからね
いきなり母親に変な人が来ているんだよと
そしたら母親は何のことなく外出ていったら
まあものをもらいたくて来た
まずい人で で で 何か米とかいろいろ持ってきながら
すぐ私に先に怒ったんです
人を侮辱するなよと お前らもうずっとそのままでいると思ってるんでしょうかと
悪いことをしたら 人をこうやってけなしたら
自分にもそういうこと変わってきますからね
覚えときなさい それっきり
どんな障害 誰の人見たっても
何とも心の中に出てこないんです
変な人とかね 気持ち悪いとか出てこない
潰されたんです それは差別感
だから決して日本から考えれば
別にそんなこと言えないでしょうね
だからこの失礼じゃない
それは人の侮辱 尊厳を侮辱する
傷つけることじゃないんです
それこそ尊厳を守ってあげることなんです
あんたはこの世だけじゃなくて
あの世でも幸福にいなさいという意味なんです
だからもう子供が学校に行こうとさっさと走る
あんたカバン持った？宿題持った？弁当は？あとは母親聞くでしょう
だから見方次第 バカにするんじゃないよと
私も堂々たる人間だよと思ったら
子供がそう思ったら侮辱されてますね
でも子供はそう思わない
なぜかというと 母親侮辱してないんです
ただ単に まあどうせ子供ははしゃいでいるんだから
何か忘れちゃうと なんか必ず忘れちゃいますよと
知ってますから 一人一人チェックしてあげることだけですよ
それは侮辱じゃない あんたもやってると思いますよ
そういうことで あの侮辱じゃないんだけど
言える場合も言えない場合も当然があります
仲間では言えます 言えない場合もあります
気をつけて気をつけましょう
はい ありがとうございます
先ほど出た方  はい こちら
もうあなた方こっちの前に行ってるの見えますよ
どちらが先に手を挙げるか
ここら辺で待っていれば
こうやって見ていれば見えます
後ろからはなかなか見えないんです
嫌だったらここら辺でいいんですよ
この方が  はい こちら  最初のところで
あのえっと 今も尊厳って出たんですけども
人のプライド 尊厳を大事にするならば
何が起こっても笑って生活できるってこうお話を聞いたんですけども
その具体的にですけど
そのプライドとか尊厳を大事にするっていうのはわかってても
ちょっと抽象的で 一つ一つ具体的にどういうことなのかな
具体的に言えば みんな同じ生命
平等だと思うことですよ
例えば部下を叱っても
部下も自分も同じ人間であって
同じ立場なんですよ だからみんな私と同じだと思っちゃえば
自分には言われて欲しくないものは相手に言わないっていうことなんです
でも自分が冗談を言われるのは好きでしょうし
だから自分に言われて好きな冗談を相手にも言う
大体そんなに難しくないで
すべての生命はもう生命として平等なんです
だから猫にでも何か大通り叫ぶと猫喜んじゃいますよ
だからまあ あまり抽象的なものじゃないんです
一応 例えば今 例を具体的に言ったでしょ？なんて馬鹿じゃないかということは侮辱なんです
あのね ずっと馬鹿なことばっかりやって困るんだから
たまたま賢いこともやってくださいと
たまたまでもいいんだから
賢いことをやってくださいと言うと
なんとなく面白くなっちゃうんです
特に私はそういうやり方で子供を管理するんです
今日だけいいんだから静かにしてくれると
で 子供は悪魔ある面ですごく厳しい言い方ですけど
今日だけ賢い子でいてくれる
言うと なんかもうかなり効き目があるんです
で 逆にまあ相手は子供だからね
まあ構いませんだけど
子供はしっかり覚えちゃうんですね
だからどうせ子供は変なことするのは普通だから
何かしそうになると 無視するか
ちょっとレベルが出て
レベルのところが出てくると見れば十分です
見ていけばそれだけでわかるんです
そういうわけで この相手をすごく愛さないと慈しめないと
この子も私は昨日夜 ものすごくもう侮辱的にすごい厳しいことを言ったんです
いろいろやってることは変なことばっかり
縁起ながらね こんなこともやってるでしょ
こんなこともやってるでしょとかね
逆にものすごい散々非難してますけど
本人がゲラゲラ笑ってるんです
効き目ないなと 普通だったらかなり落ち込むはずの単語なんですけど
やっぱり私は悪い行為を示してあげてるだけであって
本人のことは大事にしているっていうことはもう変わらないんだから
本人が第三者のこと言ってるやと勘違いする
あまり笑っちゃうんだから
私はもういいやと諦めたんです
そういうことでね あの叱ったり怒鳴ったりすることは良くないんです
まあやり方があるんです
そのやり方はどうやってというと
この尊厳ですね やっぱり全ての生命は平等であって
尊いだよと それはたとえ部下であろうとも
今日会社に入った人であろうとも関係ないんですよ
例えば会社にね いろいろオートバイでね
資料を運んでくれたりする人々いるでしょうね
だからこの宅急便屋さんでも
まあほんの二 三秒しか
もう十秒二十秒しかいないんですよ
やっぱりその間でも やっぱりその
コミュニケーションというかね
丁寧に扱うというね だから私の場合はいろいろ部屋にいない時は宅急便でいろいろ本を注文したりしますけど
いなくたっても大丈夫です
電話かけた途端にあれこれ言う必要もないんです
荷物ですけど 名前はスマナサーラで
ああ わかりました 今持ってきますと
だから番号まあいいわと言って
向こうはもう知ってるんです
だからあの二 三秒でもなんとなく関係が成り立ったっていうことなんです
はい そういうことで頑張ってみてください
はい  うちの方の方で  あのジャイナ教の先生が多数
行為によって導かれるっておっしゃったのを
お釈迦様がそれは違うよっておっしゃったところの違いがちょっと私にはわからなくて
同じに聞こえたんですが
その違いがところというのは
お釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
我々瞬間瞬間行う行為
すべて結果出るんです
だからずっと我々は行為しているんですよ
瞬間瞬間 だから結果はこの瞬間瞬間の行為を計算して言わなくちゃいけないんです
この心の瞬間論は あの他宗教の方は知らなかったんです
この魂論を持っていたんだからね
そこは裏の話で お釈迦様はなんでそういうことを言ったのかって
そちらにも裏があるんだから
だから冗談を言う前にかなり研究しなくちゃいけないんです
そういうわけで いつでも我々は行為しています
そこで殺生したことだけハイライトして
あんたもうもうそんなことばっかしやってるんだから
地獄に落ちるぞと言ったっても
その人はそんなことばっかしやってるわけじゃないんです
田んぼも作るし 料理も作るし
仕事にも行くし まあ友達を助けてあげたり
いろんなことをやってますよ
生きてる上で それの中でも殺生もしたっちゃっていうことで
だからそれだけ取ったのは悪いということで
たくさん行った行為によって運命が定めるならば
殺生する人は地獄に落ちませんよというのはすごい論理的なんです
多数に行ったことといったら
誰が多数に殺生するんですかね
これはちょっと他のどなたか口が上手な人が説明すればちょっと理解できないみたいですけど
これ私の言葉の問題だと思います
説明の 殺生は悪いんですよ
殺生する人はもう悪 あの不幸に陥る可能性はあります
なぜかというと 殺生してそれを喜んだりする
今日はもう魚もでっかい魚 4匹も取れたぞとか
1 年間も自慢する そこも悪行為なんです
仏教とはそれやらないんです
よくあるでしょ 魚する人々はもうもう写真撮って貼っておいて
毎日見て 昔ね よく魚取れたもんだなとか
年取ってからそれまで自慢したりとか
その人は殺生の行為を多数にしているんです
思い出して 思い出して思い出して
そこは破ってくださいとブッダの話なんです
ブッダが殺生するなかれと言ったら
もうお釈迦様が言うのはわかりますけど
でも私がもう結構やっているんだよと
あ これまずいとと思ったところで
それ切れちゃうんです
まずい まずい これはもうかっこ悪い
じゃあ殺生やめると それから慈悲の実践する
慈悲の実践すると 無量のパワーが入ってるんです
良いパワーが 無量の良いパワーが入っちゃうと
有量の制限ある小さな力っていうのはもう気に効き目がなくなっちゃうんです
まあ億万長者からね  1円
誰 1円誰かが取ったんだからといって
その人はもうひどい目に遭うってことないでしょう
だって無料のお金ありますからね
10万円しか持ってない私の財布から誰かが 2万円取っちゃうと
かなり効き目がありますよ
だからこの徳の量の問題なんです
明確に何がわからないかを知ったら
もうちょっと説明できると思いますけど
読まれで そちらの思考パターンと私の喋り方の思考パターンっていうのはちょっと合わないんです
誰かが説明してあげればできますか？ できますね
まあ私の思考がおかしいかも
いや もしかすると早川さんにできるかも
どういうところがわからないんですか？ちょうどが
あの慈しみの瞑想を無料だとおっしゃっているのは
多数の行為なんじゃないかなと思っちゃったんです
その一回した行為を消すっていうのは
別の思考に置き換えるのを多数に置き換えるってことだから
それも多数なんじゃないかというふうに思ってしまったんです
ん？どういうこと？ん？ 多数
多数 うん だからあの多数の行為が結果出すってことは正しいんです
あの人の言い方が間違ってるんだと
それだけ だからお釈迦様が本当に多層の声を教えてくれたんです
慈しみはもう日々やっていることだから
だから慈しみの実践は毎日やることで
できればいつでもやってくださいと言っていて
その気持ちが入ったら
生命が幸せでありますようにという
その気持ちで生きているたびに
自分が良いことをしているんです
だからもう数えられないほど良いことをしているんです
それが結果出すんだよっていうことなんです
はい  はい 今のところで
ですね 私なりの理解  はいはいはい
説明してみたいと思うんですけども
以前 先生がジャイナ教と仏教の話で
ジャイナ教は好意を体による行為を重視するけれども
仏教は心による行為を重視するとおっしゃった話が
そのままこの話にも出ていると私は考えた
つまり 体による行為として行ったことを重視する限りは
体によってというか 仏教の場合は心によるその行為をカウントすると
であるから たとえ体でやらなくても
心で悪いことをぐるぐるやってれば
それが出るのではないですかと
いう話をあのお釈迦様がされて
質問されたそのガーディーさんは
そのことに思い至らずにですね
心を行為にカウントしてなくてですね
そのそのことをお釈迦様が指摘されたんじゃないかなと
はいはい これはもうとても立派な説明だと思います
あの殺生は体でするんです
私はもう一度繰り返します
殺生は体でするんです
それは一回で終わっちゃいます
殺したら終わりですからね
それはほんの時間もかかりません
しかし 頭で考えることは絶えず起きてるんです
だから心で行為することは
いつでも多数無数になるんです
だからお釈迦様がどうしても心の方が重視するんです
うん ありがとうございます
はい  他の方ご質問ありません
こちらの右側 右の端の真ん中の方
今日の題からちょっと離れてしまうのですが
身体ではなくて知能に遅れがある人の方が
例えば人の話がよくわからない方とかに方を
慈悲の心とか そういう仏教的に良い方向へ育てていくには
仏教的にはどういうアプローチをするのかなっていうか
どういう何かアルバイトがないかなと思うんですけど
うん まあそれもやっぱり程度によりますから
程度によって何とかしなくちゃいけないんですよ
とにかくは 何であっても明るく笑っていられるようにしてあげれば
例えば知識的な能力が低く
場合はね まあ簡単に怒りとかね
嫉妬とか出てくる可能性あるんですよ
そこは普通に考える我々は気をつけて
相手が怒れないように
怒ったらちょこっと笑ったりして
なんとか冗談言ったりして明るくさせるんですね
そうするとそちらの心は綺麗に清らかになっていくんです
大体今日のテーマもそのために作ったんですけど
とにかく笑いましょうと
と言ったらすごい俗っぽいですよ
だからこういうスタイルで喋ったんです
とにかく笑いましょうではないんです
やっぱり明るくいることなんです
とにかく笑っちゃうと何かガキっぽいだから
それお釈迦様禁止てるんだからね
だからもう特に知識レベルの方で問題がある場合
認識理解レベルの問題がある場合は怒りやすいんです
感情を出す すぐ出しちゃうんです
エネルギーないんです
それに我々もなんであんたはという投資絶対取ってはいけないんです
例えば体も弱い人々はね
みんなに支えられて生きているのに
ちょっと車椅子の押し方がちょこっと失敗しただけでも怒ったりする場合あるんです
立たせてあげる時でも
ちょっと失敗したらすごく怒ったりするんです
その時 面倒見る人々はなんだこれやって思うかもしれませんだけど
その時頑張らなきゃいけないんです
それが自分の修行だと思うんです
ちょっと間違ったらかなり怒られる
怒るよとかね しかし 私がないと生きていられないぞとかね
そこで自分が相手の心を怒らないように
いつでもちょこっと笑わせるんです
その方しかないと思います
しかし それなりの知識レベルによります
で 全くもうほとんどできない場合でも笑うことはできますね
はい  他にご質問ございますでしょうか
すいません えーと 今日のお話を 3回くらい聞かせていただきました
自分も田舎で育ったもんですから
小さい頃から仏教的という日本の仏教的という環境の中で育ちました
でお話を伺って思ったことは
非常に合理的な考え方
非常にロジカルです で
ロジカルとですね 基本的に私も日本人でありますし
日本人の情緒的な考え
ここはですね どうも時々自分の中でコンフリクトしちゃうなと
それがね ロジカルで割り切らなきゃいけないんだけれども
実際それを行動として出すと
周りとコンフリクトしてしまう
言ってらっしゃる意味はわかる
つまり 先ほど言ったように
心の中で明るくなっちゃう
すぐ自分を転換してロジカルに割り切って
だけど周りムードに揺らしてくれるんだですね
その辺の例えば会社でもですね
コミュニティの中やっても非常に重要と思われる案件を
皆さん真剣な顔で議論してらっしゃるんですがとか非常に面白い
そんな時ですね なかなかそれは会社生活みたいな何か思ったりするんですけども
答えを求めているわけではなくてですね
そういう情緒的なものっていうのは
長老から見て一つの何かバリアスと考えられます
一つの障害に理解していただいても
あの情緒的なところは
この一部正しい 一部悪いということがあるんですよ
全ての生命は平等で 見る気持ちとかね
人のことを心配する気持ちとかね
人は誰であっても良くなってほしいとかね
まあみんな仲良くすればよろしいとかね
自分に関係ないんだけど
他の若い夫婦が子供とぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃと楽しそうに遊んでると
なんて美しいでしょうかとかね
そういう風に見るところはよろしいんですよ
情緒的と言っても そこに怒りが入ってくるわ
嫉妬が入ってくるわ 自我が入ってくるわ
例えば自我で情状的情緒的ということで
ものすごくとにかくやれという風に
もう戦おうではないかとかね
頑張ろう ファイトとか
なんかそういうのはね
怒りにつながるんだから
そこはよくないんですね
それから この情調と同時にこの理性がないんです
そこを気をつけた方がいくらでも
この理性ということが基本です
仏教は私が教えている
仏教ではもう感情でもなく
信仰でもなく 拝むこともなく
理性まず大事という 例えばお釈迦様に拝んでもいいんですけど
理性が必要なんです こういう素晴らしい教えを教えたんだから
もう感謝しますと 師匠として拝みますと
我々は仏像にいつでも拝むのは師匠ですよ
偉大なる師匠で もう杉さんのごとく立っているんだと
もう敵わないんだということで
自分がすごく謙虚で頭を下げるという
そちらも理性が必要ではあるんです
例えば質問されたことありますよ
あなた方は偉そうなこと言ったっても
偶像崇拝しているんではないかと
すぐ我々は絶対やりませんと
偶像崇拝は 我々はお釈迦様を拝んでるんであって
仏像を拝んでるんじゃないんだよと
だからまあ お釈迦様を拝む場合は仏像を大事にしますけど
それ終わってから まあこれはちょっとペンキでも塗ってやろうか
もうホコリでも立て だからそういうとこはもう乗ったりもします
だから別に偶像崇拝ではなくて
即ちであるのはちゃんとした
この偉大なる師匠をに尊敬することであるということで
だから あの情調の場合は一部良いものがありますから
その良いものはまあ使う
構いません どちらにしても
あんまり情調的になっちゃうと
理性っていうのは人かくれ人かくれもなく消えちゃうんです
それ危ないんです そういうところで中道を保つんです
だから感情は一切やめなさいということじゃないんです
慈悲喜捨の感情は OK なんです
一切の生命を哀れむ感情がまあ sufficient しています
それ以外のものは危険だと
感情っていうのは理性がないっていう意味なんです
例えば皆様経験あるでしょうね
女性と話してみると あんたなんであの人のことを嫌いですか？と
嫌いだから嫌いですよと言うんです
男にはその理屈わからないでしょう
嫌いだから嫌いじゃなくて
なんで嫌いですかと聞いてますよと
決して女性は言わないんですよ
こういうことをして こういうことをして
こういうことをしたいんだ
したんだから嫌いになりましたよと
男に聞けば なんであんた
あの人のことをそんなに嫌いでしょうかというと
まあこれこれこれやだから嫌いですよとはっきり言うんです
だからこの理屈はないんですね
私にある女性が教えてくれたんです
嫌いだから嫌いですよということは
これは女性の論理だよと
ちゃんと理屈通ってますよと
それで私は考えたら なるほどよくわかりましたと
わかったんです 最初からもう理由もなく
ただ気持ち的に感情的にもう嫌いってことを生まれたんです
だから嫌いですよという話なんです
そう見るのはなるほどと理解できましたけど
しかし問題は その嫌いになったことをどうやって直してあげようかと
これができないんですね
せならば もともと感情だから
理性で理性に何か理性でなくても理屈でもいいんだけど
理屈でも嫌いになった場合は
この理屈くずしちゃえばまた治るんです
例えば ある人が私の仕事にすごいダメージを与えたと
それは 邪魔をした それは腹が立つ
腹が立って その人は敵やと思っている
ライバルだと いろいろ
それで三人目の人が来てね
あんたはなんであの人をそんなにいじめているんでしょうかというと
あ この人はね この五十五年前でこういうことをしましたよと
だから嫌いたい と まあその話をわかり
まあそれはもう じゃあその人に聞いてみましょうと
あんたこの時こう邪魔したでしょうと
あ あれはもうこういうことで
あの こうなったんですけど
それ邪魔と思ったら本当に申し訳ありませんと
そのつもりではなかったと
間違えましたと言われると
ああ そうか では仲直りします
仲直りできるんですよ
だから感情で悪い感情でも
何か理屈があれば直せます
理屈がないとどうにもならんです
あの そこはこの名前を言いたくはないんだけど
ある宗教もよく使ってるんですよ
あの 禁止するんですね
理性を 他の人の話聞くなよと
他の本を読むなよと  例えばトルコにしたっても
このほとんどが英語で書いてる本なんか翻訳もしない
そうやってこの理性にもうなんて言いますか
この障害かけておくんですね
そうなってくると この自分の感情で
信仰で貫くことできると
仏教は全く反対なんです
何でもオープンにしなさいと
ということで まあブッダの仏教は
まあ仏教はいろいろブッダでない人も仏教という場合がありますからね
今はお釈迦様の仏教はもう本当に理性っていうのは大事なんです
ではだいぶ時間も押しておりますので
もし質問がなければこれで終了といたします
えっと 次回なんですが
次回はちょっと連続的になっておりまして
五月の二十三日の金曜日の夜からですね
何時からですかね 六時半から
今日と同じ場所でえー
講演会になります ちょっと夜遅いですけど
お仕事帰りなどにお誘い合わせの上で来ていただければと思います
はい では最後の祝福を唱えて終了いたします
合掌してください サンビーディオーヴィワンジャントゥサンバローゴーヴィナッストゥマーテーバワンワンタラヨースキーディーガーユコバワババトゥサンバマンガラ
ンラッカントゥサンバデーヴァタサンバブッダヌバーヴェナサダースッティバワントゥテーババトゥサンバマンガランラッカントゥサンバデーヴァタサンバダンマヌバー
ヴェナサダースッティバワントゥテーババトゥサンバマンガランラッカントゥサンバデーヴァタサンバサンガヌバーヴェナサダースッティバワントゥテーアビワダナシ
ーリーッサーニッチャンワンダパチャイノーチャントーヨダンマーワンダンティーラーユワッノーシュカンバランアーユラーローギャサンパッティサンガサンパッティ
ミーワチャーアトーニンバーナサンパッティミナテーサミンジョトゥ
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます